you guys are eminent domain is
absolutely no idea I own it love that to
do it the internet I'm a Taurus know
what he's wet where does that mean I'm
thinking domain that's just my domain I
own it ah but I forgot it's dim that on
it right maybe they domain
okay well I'm anti eminent domain this
hey Here I am at the corner of Hollywood
and Vine beautiful Hollywood California
you know ten years ago this wasn't such
a great neighborhood it's a lot of drug
dealing going on a lot of hookers tours
didn't feel safe walking around here but
back then some people took chances and
invested their money here in Hollywood
and helped turn the whole area around
now it's pretty much safe place to be
and a lot of tourists and that's a
credit to these people who are willing
to take a risk ten years ago to invest
their money right here in Hollywood one
of these risk takers was Craig Trager we
caught up with Craig at his bar at the
well where he talked about another bar
he used to own called Daddy's 1995
Hollywood was dormant and it was the
same pretty much up until about five six
years ago a lot of t-shirt stores not
much activity 1995 we went in there and
there was nothing open on vine in the
very beginning it was rough I was pretty
much there five six nights a week by
myself with a couple books in hand
because we wouldn't see a single
customer so about 11:00 11:30 because we
were hell-bent on making sure that it
was word of mouth that made us popular
eventually daddy's became a cool place
to hang out
I had celebrities that were famous and I
had people that are now famous and I
think what a lot of people really loved
about daddies was that we don't have
guest lists we don't do the velvet rope
which enables people to have a manatee
wherever they go and it's really hard
for those people so they know that
daddy's was the safe haven you know to
see somebody that you'd like to see and
that you like to talk to customers may
have like daddies but the city decided
that it had to go
initially the way we found out was we
got a letter in the mail to the bar
that's basically invited us and all the
business people in Hollywood to come see
a development project that was going to
really be an amazing project for
Hollywood Dennis Cavallari is vice
president
at Legacy Partners the company that's
redeveloping the Hollywood and Vine area
it includes 300 w hotel rooms 150 W
condos 375 luxury apartments and then
about 50,000 square feet of retail in
the ground floor and there was these
beautiful models in it and it looked
amazing as I'm looking at this project I
noticed that it's on vine encompasses
the whole block of vine summon all the
way around and there's no daddies that I
mean my bar is gone so I went up to the
people from the legacy in the CRA and I
said it's a great project but what about
me and they basically really just kind
of like blew me off really like I didn't
matter you know the great thing about
America is what you want property you
own it am i right you can do anything
you want with that property you can
build a house on it business you can
plant flowers grow daisies whatever you
want to do with it it's your property
you own it and the only way somebody can
take your property is if they steal it
am i right
that's why the government invented
eminent domain I didn't know what
eminent domain met honestly I never even
heard the word you have
come and take it from you or something
they're just walking in and say okay I'm
going to give you this amount of money
and whether you want it or not they've
made a decision that they need this
property for something they're working
on
traditionally governments only use them
in a domain to build roads schools and
other public projects but now cities
routinely use eminent domain to transfer
property to developers in order to build
things like fancy condos and hotels
which they hope will generate more tax
revenue for the city the last night we
had been informed with what our last
date was gonna be
they put a myspace thing for months
before that saved daddies and hundreds
of the hundreds of people would go on
there and talk about what they loved
about daddies and I got to really see
all the relationships that I wasn't even
aware of people who had met people who
had got married I rented a photo booth
and we put it inside we pretty much let
some people take some things as you know
some people wanted the bar stool that
they sat on for all those years it was
one of the best parties I've been to
everybody when they left wrote on the
outside of the building some things that
were nice to us to the bar and some
night things that really weren't too
nice to the city what do I say to a guy
like Craig unfortunately I you know I
think it's a situation where he needs a
needs to go out look for a new location
the land owners had sold their property
in here realized some huge gains the the
numbers we spent have paid for the land
and here our record numbers for
Hollywood you know from where we sit in
our vantage point we're really thinking
that everybody is to benefit from this
redevelopment project it wasn't a win
for me it wasn't a win for probably most
of the 30 business owners it's
definitely not a win for her Clark who
owned the property of Daddy's because he
had had that building in his family for
so many years believing in the
redevelopment of Hollywood believing
that he one day would sell it and make
money in all those years and instead
they set market rate he gets what they
tell him he's gonna get and he goes this
is where daddy's used to be about 30
other businesses were also forced out
without eminent domain in place or the
threat of eminent domain I seriously
doubt that this property theirs or this
development could take place
isn't there a better way you know
someplace where everybody could just get
along well yeah there is it's just down
the street from the happiest place on
earth
in Anaheim California we spoke with
Anaheim mayor Kirk Pringle about his
innovative approach to redevelopment
what we're trying to do is just make
sure we have a proper and respectful
model for development much of Anaheim
used to look like these industrial
buildings but recently all kinds of
fancy new developments have been
breaking ground Anaheim's getting the
same kind of revitalization Hollywood
wants but it's using a different process
a lot of folks along the path have said
you have to use eminent domain to
develop a older area others would say
you have to have a very firm set of
zoning requirements and that's the only
way that people will build in certain
areas here in Anaheim we've actually
taken the opposite approach and in fact
when it comes to zoning we have given
flexibility to developers to decide do
they want to build industrial or
residential maybe mixed-use with some
commercial Anaheim's redevelopment plans
started years after hollywood's but it's
progressing much faster folks are
already moving into stadium lofts and a
town isn't far behind
a town is going to have about 4,000
homes and all the way from low rise to
high rise as well as a is about two
hundred and fifty thousand square feet
of retail emile Haddad works for Lennar
the company that's building a 10 we
assembled 30 properties from 30
different owners we did all of that
through negotiation the big a town
complex will be located right next to
the smaller business but what's really
cool is the smaller business wasn't
forced out that's good news for owner
Chuck Nieman Linares representatives did
approach me on the property and they
gave me what would be a fair price for
the property but it didn't cover any of
our costs that we would incur our
property taxes would go up by about
20,000 dollars a year to buy a new
building at today's market prices we'd
have the cost of relocation the moving
cost of probably the biggest cost is
loss of business and taking our people
away from what they do
to plan and and and activate the move
many other cities would a forced Chuck's
company to leave if this was in some
other city and they took our property by
him and it domain I feel it's very
possible that we would have gone out of
business and not using eminent domain we
are seeing great results within our
community with regards to the city of
Anaheim and their incentives for
redevelopment in and around Angel
Stadium I'm not that familiar with what
they're doing over there but from what I
can understand from a distance it sounds
like it's a very creative approach to
redevelopment I think what we're doing
here can be replicated it all depends on
if there's a will to do it it's a very
very difficult thing and like I said
previously there's no right and wrong
and eminent domain I mean in domain is
like cancer eminent domain for us is it
was completely like you've been
diagnosed you don't know how long you
have to live there's a little shred of
hope that somebody might wait legally
win and you're just waiting to die hey
so it's 2007 right now and now it's an
empty lot but who knows maybe twenty
years from now just when the W Hotel is
making a profit somebody with deeper
pockets is gonna come along steal their
land with them enough domain and build
something better